ce
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle édition du 7 8
l'aktu du jeudi 27 février comme tous
les jours vous en avez l'habitude nous
allons faire le point complet sur votre
actualité locale tout d'abord cette
information sportive ou extra sportives
nous vous en parlions il ya dans notre
édition environ 200 personnes
lié au club de football de trappes
éducateurs parents et enfants ont
manifesté hier devant la mairie ils
réclament la construction d'un nouveau
terrain synthétique notamment la
réhabilitation de leur infrastructure
existante les terrains impraticables ou
des vestiaires aux normes une action
suivie d'effets puisque une délégation
est en ce moment même reçue par le maire
guy malandain compte rendu complet de ce
nouvel entretien dans notre édition du 7
8 l'aktu demain vendredi 28 février en
politique de 39 le nombre de cantons
dans le département devrait passer à 21
si l'on en croit le projet de découpage
de la préfecture un projet que
n'apprécie guère la majorité de droite
du conseil général des yvelines qui le
contestent aujourd'hui devant le conseil
d'état
explications de wilfrid riches
villepreux qui rejoint à bois d'arcy et
fontenay le fleury le canton de saint
cyr l'école ne comptera plus trois
communes mais quatre maurepas et
l'encours et la verrière rapprocher de
trappes un changement pour ces trois
villes appartenant auparavant aux mêmes
cantons que coignières deux des
principaux changements dans les yvelines
suite au redécoupage des cantons qui
restent contestés par la majorité de
droite au conseil général
malgré les prises de position des élus
et les recommandations du conseil d'état
le décret finale n'a pas évolué et vient
d'être dévoilée ce 26 février
certains élus parlent donc le charcutage
électoral et devraient se mobiliser dans
les prochains mois puisque la
conséquence première sera de changer
fortement la donne pour la prochaine
élection cantonale en 2015
rappelons que jusqu'à présent le
département comptait 39 cantons pour 39
élus au conseil général
la nouvelle répartition des quelques 260
de commune yvelinoise doit permettre de
réaliser des économies le même type de
redécoupage s'applique d'ailleurs
partout en france
le déficit de l'université de versailles
saint quentin a des répercussions au
delà du département l'ancienne
présidente sylvie faucheux vient de
perdre son poste de rectrice de
l'académie de dijon
dans une lettre ouverte elle estime que
ce remplacement est directement liée à
la situation financière de l'université
catherine du lat
le 1er mars l'université de versailles
saint quentin aura enfin son budget 2014
présenté par le rectorat
il devrait se composer d'une aide
financière de l'état sous forme d'une
avance remboursable et d'économies
supplémentaires à réaliser par
l'établissement établissement qui
affiche un déficit de plus de 5 millions
d'euros
un dossier compliqué qui s'étend
maintenant delà du département
car l'ancienne présidente de
l'université sylvie faucheux vient de
perdre mercredi son poste de rectrice de
l'académie de dijon poste qu'elle
occupait depuis 2012 pour rappel sylvie
faucheux avait été président de
l'université de 2002 à mars 2012 et dans
une lettre ouverte rédigée ce 26 février
elle ne mâche pas ses mots et estime que
l'origine de ce déplacement est liée à
la situation financière délicate que
traverse l'université
elle dénonce également des injonctions
invectives du président actuel à l'égard
de la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche
un remplacement qui est aussi peut être
liée à la sortie prochaine d'un rapport
de la cour des comptes qui mettrait en
cause sa gestion à la tête de
l'université un dossier loin d'être plus
loin
ce lundi à versailles une trentaine de
jeunes majeurs sans papiers ont
rencontré leurs nouveaux parrains et
marraines depuis plusieurs années le
réseau éducation sans frontières des
yvelines organise ce type de rencontre
pour protéger justement les jeunes
scolarisés qui vivent sous la menace
d'une expulsion pardon et mes invités
tout juste rentré de la préfecture
viennent tant par les audits johan
bonsoir à vous vous êtes membre du
réseau éducation sans frontières des
evil histoire à vous vous êtes
accompagné de jean claude maréchal
parent d'un jeune majeur justement qui
qui est en pleine procédure tout d'abord
première question comment s'est passée
cette réunion cet après-midi à la
préfecture lui alors ben bien il faut
dire que c'est pas la première fois
qu'on est reçue en préfecture que chaque
fois qu'il ya une demande de notre part
avec une liste de jeunes là lui c'est
toujours accepté parce qu'il veut pas
dire qu'elle est toujours favorable pour
tous les jeunes
mais les relations sont très bonnes
d'autant plus que quand une mobilisation
avant très réussie side sûr c'est sur
ces jeunes justement qui postulait vous
me disais qu'ils avaient quand même
parfois des refus ça peut arriver
il n'y a pas 100 % de réussite l'année
dernière on avait déposé au mois de mai
quatorze noms sur les quatorze noms il
ya eu un refus qui d'ailleurs fait
partie maintenant des 29 noms trop donné
aujourd'hui et il ya eu 2 qui n'étaient
pas vraiment des refus mais des
acceptations de rester son territoire
pour un peu de temps seulement les
médias continuent alors l'objectif de
votre mobilisation c'est évidemment de
protéger ces jeunes qui sont scolarisés
et qu'ils sont sous menace on part du
principe que tout jeune qui est
scolarisé est en formation sur le
territoire et c'est une marque
d'intégration et donc que tous ces
jeunes là ont leur place pour s'ils le
souhaitent rester en france pour
construire l'envi une fois qu'ils sont
majeurs en fin de compte vous prenez un
petit peu le relais de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance puisque ils sont pris en
charge par l'aide sociale à l'enfance
jusqu'à l'âge de
18 ans que derrière il n'y a plus rien
en fait alors c'est pas exactement ça on
dépend d'abord il ya deux sortes de
jeunes il ya ceux qui effectivement sont
pris en charge par l'aide à l'enfance
qu'on appelle les au départ les mineurs
isolés étrangers et qui effectivement à
18 ans ont des problèmes mais je pense
que jean-claude en parlera beaucoup
mieux que moi puisque son filleul et
dans ce cas là et puis il ya et jusqu'à
maintenant beaucoup plus
aro sf des jeunes en famille saveurs des
jeunes venus ou avec des parents qui
sont encore sans papiers ou rejoindre un
non plus une tente un frère une soeur
qui sont en france deux filets des x 10
ou 20 ans mais sous prétexte que leurs
parents sont restés au pays n'ont pas de
papiers vous parliez du parrainage
justement de jean claude maréchal vous
êtes donc parent d'un jeune pourquoi
avoir déjà décidé de devenir parents
j'ai décidé d'accepter d'être parent
parce que je rencontre pas mal de jeunes
sans papiers au sein d'une permanence
contient versailles tous les vendredis
après midi et que j'ai vu la détresse de
beaucoup d'entre eux j'ai des petits
enfants
j'ai pas envie que d'autres soient moins
heureux que et il faut le rappeler vous
êtes par un milieu aussi en fait il y a
deux parrains en sept ans ce dispositif
il ya vous est toujours à côté un élu
pour un an voyez là dans ce cas là c'est
sandrine grand gang qui est élue
régionale des yvelines est alors pour le
jeune que vous parrainez qui a été sa
situation sa situation c'est un jeune
malien qui est venue en france
en 2012 c'était en pleine guerre du
nord-mali il était du nord-mali lui-même
ses parents et ses frères étaient
décédés il est venu par l'italie il
aboutit en france et là il a été pris en
charge par la seule ils avaient moins de
18 ans et il a été placé au bout d'un an
à peu près dans un centre d'éducation et
de formation en internat et avec une
formation d'abord en français parce
qu'au départ ils ne parlaient que la
langue de son pays et il a été il a
commencé une formation en horticulture
en janvier il a atteint ses 18 ans et le
le conseil général n'a pas voulu
renouveler son contrat en contrat de
jeunes majeurs il le foyer qu'il
l'hébergeait recevait une subvention une
indemnisation du conseil général et a
dit bon bah on peut pas garder ce jeune
on va le garder jusqu
début mars et dure pour vous prenez le
relais prendre le relais peuvent pas
forcément on cherche à les aider à
trouver une solution et notamment à lui
permettre d'obtenir un titre de séjour
est de trouver une formation continuée
par exemple dans la formation horticole
de qu'il souhaitait mener jusqu'au bout
par rapport à ces demandes que vous avez
fait vous avez bon espoir sur un an on
va dire un chiffre peut-être sur ses
ailes avant de parler de chiffres je
vais vous dire justement que quand on
prend le relais
c'est un volet purement de médiation par
rapport à la préfecture certes on n'est
pas là pour les loger on n'est pas là
pour les nourrir on n'est pas là pour
remplacer la famille qu'ils n'ont plus
et l'état qu 'il conseil général n'est
pas son travail mais on est uniquement
là pour faire accélérer les choses pour
qu'ils soutiennent autonome et dans ce
cas précis de ce jeune descoings a
trouvé un patron qui accepte de le
prendre en alternance on à l'engagement
de la préfecture et un engagement solide
un pas une promesse en l'air qui
seraient immédiatement ils auraient
droit au travail ça veut dire te pour
lui précisément je pense que la réunion
était positive et du coup sûr ces jeunes
qui sont en lice pour justement avoir un
nouveau titre de séjour vous avez bon
espoir au pas pour tous sur le 29 non on
va pas faire des pronostics mais disons
pour une grande partie je pense que à
court terme ou à moyen terme
on a bon espoir absolument et puis pour
les suivants bon continuera très bien
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'être
venu témoigner de votre mobilisation sur
le 7-8 lecture on suivra ça de près
évidemment s'il ya des changements merci
beaucoup
la serre aux papillons de la
queue-lez-yvelines entame sa nouvelle
saison une quarantaine d'espèces volts
en liberté dans un climat de forêt
amazonienne l'occasion de voyager de
partir à la découverte de ces insectes
éphémère et mystérieux yolaine thorez
les observer pour nous
nous voici dans la jungle équatoriale de
la queue-lez-yvelines plus de 7 100
papillon vole en liberté parmi les
visiteurs on les reçoit des philippines
du costa rica de guyane martinique
on les reçoit donc en chrysalide et les
chrysalides font installer ensuite dans
les écluses war et à partir de ses
épaules voire les papiers on s le matin
une fois qu'ils sont nés ils déploient
leurs ailes
entre 30 minutes et deux heures selon
les variétés les papillons sont ensuite
libéré et se nourrissent naturellement
de plantes mais pas seulement la seule
chose qu'on a alors à leur apporter
c'est des compléments de nourriture
parce que comme il ya beaucoup de
papillons les fleurs des prés ça se fit
pas assez donc on leur met des tubes sur
des fleurs artificielles avec de l'eau
sucrée et certaines variétés se
nourrissent de fruits en fermentation
donc on leur met des assiettes avec des
bananes pourries dans un climat de forêt
amazonienne avec 28 degrés et 80 %
d'humidité
certains photographes voyage à travers
leurs clichés
une majorité de papillons d'amérique du
sud des espèces qu'on voit pas en france
c'est très agréable à regarder et à
photographier difficile au niveau
technique photo c c'est un bon exercice
les papillons c'est une merveille de la
nature et on est il faut être capable de
justement de pouvoir apprécier ce que ce
qu'ils aient donné d'une manière
gratuite adultes les papillons vivent en
moyenne trois semaines et sans son
nouveau sont apportés chaque semaine
pour renouveler la certes de très belles
espèces coloré et si vous êtes en panne
d'idées cadeaux pour la fête des
grands-mères ce dimanche sachez que la
serre aux papillons offre une place
mamie pour deux entre deux enfants deux
entrées enfants pardon à acheter
jusqu'au 3 mars prochain c'est la fin de
ce set 8 la q1 merci encore une fois de
l'avoir suivi à 18h30 vous retrouverez
filets qu avec l'air cambier quant à moi
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée
sur terrifiés